cela fait un peu plus de moi que cette
maison est interdite au public
nous sommes vus robespierre aux terres
sainville à fort de france et suite à
une opération de police menée le 27 juin
dernier neuf personnes ont été arrêtées
les dominicains espagnol français pour
des faits de proxénétisme
l' enquête a duré plusieurs mois et
choses peu habituelle a été menée par la
brigade de recherches de la police aux
frontières
dirigée par le commissaire du porge
cette affaire a débuté parce que les
policiers de ce service se sont rendus
compte que des dominicaines arrivée en
martinique pour trois mois avec des
papiers du venezuela
en effet contrairement aux habitants de
seynod mais notre législation permet un
vénézuélien de rester sur le territoire
français pendant trois mois
à leur arrivée à l'aéroport c'est
dominique lo vénézuélienne était
accueilli et raccompagné par les mêmes
personnes
vous pouvez rentrer sur le territoire
national avec le passeport en cours de
validité
mais ça ne suffit pas il vous faut aussi
normalement une réservation d'hôtel une
une certaine somme d'argent pour vivre
etc
et là on s'est aperçu que si ses filles
avait le passeport en cours de validité
en revanche n'est pas forcément le ce
qu'on appelle le viatique c'est à dire
la réservation d'hôtels et c'est donc à
partir de là on les fait suit on
s'aperçoit que c'est souvent les mêmes
dames qui viennent la récupérer à
l'aéroport qui les emmènent aux terres
sainville etc donc voilà voilà comment
débute débute l'enquêté une maison et
deux autres appartements ont été mis
sous scellé
sur les neuf personnes arrêtées quatre
ont été mises en examen pour
proxénétisme aggravé et traite d'êtres
humains aggravée l'une d'entre elles a
été incarcéré il s'agit du propriétaire
de l'un de ces appartements et oui
depuis 2016 ce ne sont plus les
prostituées que la loi pénalise mais les
propriétaires et les clients se livrer à
la prostitution n'est pas une infraction
en revanche ce qui ce qui constitue une
infraction c'est le fait d'avoir recours
à la prostitution
clairement ce sont donc les clients les
clients qui ont qui ont ainsi qui
s'adresse et kiki
bénéficie donc des déserts qui sont
ainsi réalisés par les personnes se
livrant la constitution sont coupable de
cette infraction là et ce qui demeure
une infraction parce que ça l'a toujours
été
c'est le fait d'aider la prostitution
par quelque moyen que ce soit notamment
par la mise à disposition de logements
selon certains éléments ces femmes
transiterait par la guyane avant
d'arriver en martinique puis se rendrait
en guadeloupe
le procureur lui a tenu à rappeler que
les personnes arrêtées risquent jusqu'à
dix années de prison pour proxénétisme